we can't tell them this captain I don't
see the problem but it's got the thing
thing and okay just show them the deep
ocean as my grandfather Jacques Cousteau
probably said is dark and full of
mysteries none more important to us
humans than how we went from this to
this this is the Acorn worm they have no
eyes no brain no sense organs and
subsist mostly on a diet of well dirt
they're also the link between
vertebrates and invertebrates
approximately 70% of our genes trace
their ancestry back to the Acorn worm
fascinating this phallus shaped worm was
discovered in the Burgess Shale in
Canada's Yoho National Park almost a
hundred years ago the fossil went
unnoticed until hold on
jumbo nah how's it hanging
what's wrong Philippe body's well thank
you how'd you find that warm again I was
a dismissing and DC taking a closer look
at their work force collection from the
birth shell and using modern technology
I managed to find that some of these
ones belong to a group called the Acorn
warm and I said oh my gosh this one
really connects a lot of vibration dots
in this Roman almost mentioned for more
than 500 million years do 500 million
years has sank well we think that at
some point the a cone warm up on their
appetite and opted instead to dig into
the sediment and eat mud
come on a day thanks jungle now da coin
worm the missing link between
vertebrates and invertebrates without
which we might all still be eating dirt
give it a try here it builds the immune
system